[Music]
and the crusades were let me tell you
bubba's
a while let's just call it what it is
like i said
christians verse muslims is the greatest
oldest sports rivalry in history
and this was the championship it was a
nine game series and the muslims won
eight to one they won eight to one but
but but i think when you cross over and
get the other side
i think that the christians are going to
be welcomed as the victors you think so
i think that muslims have an unfair
advantage because allah is the only true
god
that's like having shaquille o'neal well
the reason why i mean the thing is with
even though
i'm a celibate kid in muslim heaven you
could just bang out virgins yeah that's
when you go to the muslim heaven and
christian evan i know if you
unless i'm going to the gay part of
heaven i'm not going to bang anybody out
i think
ultimately the the christians went up
game one
yeah so the first crusade there was nine
different crusades yeah
and the first seven were really like
kind of relevant the last three
they didn't even make it they just got
killed along well one of them one
crusade i forgot what it was a child
well not that one but that one of them
was just christian the christians went
out to crusade and then they started
crusading against each other i mean it
just turned into a [ __ ] civil war
crusade
before the christians went out and
crusaded to the middle east and started
they never had seen any other people
that didn't look like them they just
they were living in france and germany
and england and not leaving their little
islands or their little huts
so they looked barbaric like they truly
barbaric with the middle east
what everybody was clean they had soaps
they took baths
they ate the right foods they had
science so really the crusades are real
it was kind of the first kind of
movement ever where
europe got like woke europe wasn't woke
at all
before they met the muslims yeah well
way
no they were and they were with rome and
then they they dipped down
when religion dipped up we've talked
about that a lot yeah
and the arab world was flourishing they
also had conquered
all the way up to spain a little bit
yeah so they ran
spain yeah they got up in there and they
got up there i know who is this who is
his crusaders
yeah and europe got split europe was
split because of the schism of 1054.
holy roman empire was split into the
east and west and also
the cat the christian church split
between the catholic
and the eastern russian and greek
orthodox what it ended up becoming so is
eastern orthodox
and the catholics split so so europe was
[ __ ] stupid they were stupid and
everybody in the crusades what it was
all about was jerusalem
who was sent on another who jerusalem
was basically like
it was kind of like new york city no i
mean what's the most important city in
the world
new york city right so jerusalem was a
very important city to these groups
right now
it was important to the jewish it was
important to the muzzies and it was
important to the christies
because no matter what if you believe or
not the kid jesus was the star the kid
jesus sold tickets
that kid jesus sold tickets
[Music]
you